absolutely he's very very very clean
about that and this team it will make
you block forever yeah it's very good
Fievel walk back five walk back five oh
maybe I should hit a button getting into
it yeah second set of the top eight here
it's gonna be a good one
winners side winner side whatever let's
play super noon yeah I'm pretty sure we
talked about a couple times the kill
sage had said earlier that like earlier
in the week I think that he has favored
Chris G or wall to win this obviously
wah-wah unfortunately it's out however
Chris she winterside you know his
predictions could still come true yeah I
have to apologize before this tournament
I was like dude it's gonna be a wall or
shank strand finally I feel like I curse
them yeah I was like my bad dude Wallace
shanks grand finals for sure so good
unfortunately man imagine if that
happened I could totally see them making
that happen appraising this game up tech
interesting a lot of people don't like
to up tech against that cool Raphael ya
know what's this available he's gonna
have sell back you know does so well is
yeah smart brush is great his corner
routes are fantastic as well try for the
2h on incoming but the double-double
press yeah that was great and then the
discs are out there combo off of them
here we go right into the level three
Vegeta than trouble in the spark out
comes up that's a big win when you
thought the Galactic don't know what's
gonna combo I think super - after
expenses with the young trusses pizza
just yeah Gore canceled that's what
rough spot to be for vegeto right it's
not really good at fighting back like
that nice challenge from stuff you tried
to hit a button under the GT Goku
assists in case Christie ran forward
the reflect calls it out he just waited
and thought the punish on that meters
here we'll see how much he can build by
the end of this the assess bragging rush
gonna get close the sword goes nothing
yeah it's good as he takes out this
Christian loves to do this use the spear
ball and I feel like yeah you never know
if he's gonna extend it or not or he's
just gonna do one he does that a lot
that's something that he's always done
to display tomatillo and it gets to age
there though you can't do that on go
tanks that 2h is too good yeah it's
maybe the snap freeze it coming in that
was a reflective time try super - in
again I'll go change so gets clipped by
the syllabus yeah not easy to confirm
off that and no snipe on the tag he was
already up in the air
Yamcha sis's back up though yeah scared
he can test on the ground when y'all
just this is around for sure that double
jump up in the air and he just zipping
across the screen ready to catch you
with those fists super - lands wassup
combo off bit nice work from Chris
yeah choose to go for the reverse
kamehameha instead of the dragon round
or anything like that it's the combo
that doesn't look like an easy extension
actually no trying to extend it with
precesses - yeah I think mostest is it's
not so bad I don't like a little funky
snap into Frieza again no meaty from sub
probably a little easier when you have a
peanut assist that his is more of like a
black explosions yeah twice in a row
good find a punch that easy peasy 2h Oh
miss the snap their hair - empty low in
the corner to a meter off of this we're
at four bars already going into the
level one
three answer thank as much as you can
get
yeah one but one mix and it's like Old
Faithful you can't go wrong sometimes
plus you know a sister there and stuff
like it's not so bad
super - confirm off the free is SS
sparks up I like it especially just try
and gain some that meter yeah I could've
build it up meet her here extension is
huge that's marking gone I mean sub you
know he doesn't have a lot of life to
work with but that's big drop from Chris
both players playing very patient the
beyblade is out gets super dashing right
into it
to be fair it's been a while I don't
blame her it's been a while with you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] she gets beyblade he's like
maybe it'll work I'm not sure oh he know
to use his air action no cancel off the
air to H there should be the kill for it
he's out of here there's one character
left I thought it might as he changing
yeah I'm sure just because he has a lot
of health and you could use the assist
but I'm not sure he's gonna do spear
ball no save in here so get in the hit
here on gochang so this is gonna be a
dead goat a state one looking like it is
going to Chris G for a second I thought
he'd try to snipe something and then I
was like alright he's gonna do this and
then he's gonna do like you know I don't
even know I was like was spear ball
maybe to bring in Yamcha they didn't do
anything I was like okay I got spark
from stage when he was playing so now we
got an exit number one you know let's
play some bingo yeah see what other
cursed events can happen
events mistakes are made California
League Oh more awful breeze I think
isn't a lot of corner carry lots of
stagger yes because Kristen sent me a
sense so yeah he was trying to stagger
so that he could waste enough time for
bonuses to come back out of there to
gets the hit from the key blasts though
[Music]
- age hits this alysus there's a
reflects and Chris she's doing a really
good job at taking every opportunity
when he has a chance to get out the
corner to take it like he's paying
attention every time there is a gap yeah
screen space is the morning of the team
like this you don't wanna end up in the
corner yeah I think that's kind of tough
to check out of like you just barely got
hit by it so reacting there it is thanks
for charge up yeah why not take the
meter Metheny care you have to be
mindful that you didn't just spend
meters no you're not Peter bouncy but
it's very good beside that I spun it
yeah those great super - through the
diagonal beam they're getting hit by it
was clean cut level three yeah reflect
on wake up tag I like the patients there
too but still manages to get hit nearby
the jido subatomic savers taking that
corner positioning now yeah level one
for the knockdown
Chris no smarter anything yet six am
here puts himself in the corner there
yeah - what's happened to keep yourself
safe see what Chris it's gonna try and
get some opened up one of those moments
we're like the man is trying to beat the
guard council oh but then you ended up
putting yourself in such a bad spot for
and you spent the meter box up again
some sparking on defense I think is
actually very good for Chris oh that's a
reset alot of damage sparking - em
starters did not sparking is already
gone
it's the hit though just give me a dead
GT Goku yeah from stuff in the corner
those need to use the level one not big
deal those cells three bars on deck yeah
that's big win I mean Chris has two
characters marking but you know keeping
your team together in this game I think
is often we're spending here sparking
early if you put get put in a situation
when you have to look at mix-up
situation or something like that Chris
didn't feel like you need it to Dodgers
John so Oh super taxes right food does
not get clipped that's not by the
beyblade yeah even called the cell
assist actually try to hit him while
last bit of the rock drop Chris though
six am Yamcha goes low after it looked
like Chris is trying to beat that
tagging wolf actually without back foot
I'm like err level 3 or something one
thing I like to right now is when when
Christie's Riza is trying to sound I
like the spacing that subatomic sabers
is using to try and jump in and there we
go we got a hit
good punish comes up well to see
probably corner carry and we're gonna
see the final kamehameha yeah now the
the guess obviously a spark or not you
know he was waiting he was looking for a
spark looking for a tag there's the
smart kind of blocks unlocked out by the
five out I like the back off they're
gonna knock him down go right into the
spirit ball or even people think this I
think he probably wants Yamcha points
around the mix-up saw sparking is on
decks in the front table clean kill yeah
clean kill getting the vegeto out of the
way now it's only up to sell and go
tanks for subatomic sabers here yeah and
he's about to run out of this level to
sparking so pretty even match backs off
I think maybe trying to call it a tag
double talk answer you gotta love it you
gotta love it poor fullscreen no meters
so he come into now one bar we've got
another level three available if y'all
suspended okay I didn't obey believe
that shuttering around
yeah yeah that's great
he was he was definitely respecting a
lot so why not dragon rush them yeah a
while I feel like we haven't seen that
Ghost come out see if there's a
reflector not badness and he calls it
out with the 2h damage yeah goes out
energy field yeah fries eat good babies
he changed and killed with just energy
field but please clean your plate yeah I
think it's probably fine either way it's
up now chillin and you know you get good
solid stuff off was like perfect attack
go tanks block command throw he jumps it
and and I was almost gonna stay for a
second I wonder if we're gonna see cold
freeze up and I don't know this is a lot
of meter to be built off of here he
might yeah he's gonna have only a little
bit of help left after this I mean it's
fine he gives you a freeze-frame I think
that's one thing that's important about
yeah this is actually bad he's bragging
rushing and go take this out might just
be a hit a button always techadon said
okay that is HUGE
if he's able to somehow make this
comeback with both Frieza you have to
wait the change from us up there I mean
really he's just it's a it's just the
clock he's waiting out right as soon as
that pops at the end of Frieza that's
all he's waiting for anyway I think
Frieza players always are like it's
always really questionable when somebody
goes gold yeah I mean it's good in the
right circumstance especially I think if
you have spark see a lot of mystic
coming from stuff so far
there was there's definitely a bunch in
this set so far you know sometimes it's
momentum strange you gotta have those on
point those are some of the most
guaranteed pressure you get in this game
that stays on the front so far that
finishes that reflect jumps out but
catches the up back okay Sparky to get
out
ya know help vanish after either from
some pls sparks out I think we got to
see something big hair and Chris gave it
to him yeah I'm gonna spend the level
three look at the damage Yamcha took
here and this is an important part of
Chris's team
yeah reflect tag no to age I cannot
believe I thought for sure that was like
one of those moments where I was like
already like alright well sums gonna get
the 2h we'll see about the snap I was
like planning the future and there was
no to a change
oh no prank on the dragon rush oh man I
think I think that's a big big big
weakness in this right now that moment
right there might come back to haunt up
for sure missing the two aged lose and
go things because of it he's down a
sparking that's you
probably the turning point in the set as
he gets boiled whole pig dropped over
Chris but he gets it right again with
super - here so in another draw he was
very respectful enoki - I think maybe
looking for a tag or a spark breeze
assist blocked in the air tons of blocks
down low again for Chris powerful gonna
hit the corner here as he change level
three
yeah kind of trying to kill here with
the sparking and that'll do it so Chris
G sitting in a really really great spot
level ones parking on his frees us up
with one character left all free for
Chris G yeah this is a tough spot the
block - you gotta wait out sparking 606
on mini on chest says that is a good
shell to use alright two bars at the end
of this if it's
now go to the level one yeah crazy gets
it not quite enough to kill but I don't
know how you can really come back from
this with some time savers manages to
get a bit here at seven bars we should
definitely see a level three if he can
fog up no not so much
yeah I'm gonna be vanished into dragon
rush in a little three maybe but seven
meters the clash auto come a whip and
that'll do it Chris G moving on in a
wild one of a set for sure lots of
weirdness as he's gonna be playing up
against super noon in our winners final
yeah a lot of drops a lot of weird stuff
in the